All right, so now we get to the end to the
sort of closing curtain of our discussion
of this absolutely pathetic, embarrassing
ill-advised, failed rally that Donald Trump
insisted on holding in Tulsa, Oklahoma.
Donald Trump was completely furious, outraged
over the large swaths of empty seats, and
he flipped out on his own staff backstage
on Saturday.
He was completely triggered and this might
shock you.
Trump blamed everybody but himself for the
failure.
So we already discussed what Trump said at
the rally, including 20 minutes of material
about walking down a ramp and drinking water.
I was also admitted that he tried to slow
down Corona virus testing.
We also saw interviews with rally goers and
the horrors that it means about America.
We saw Trump flunkies fall apart when asked
about the lack of crowds on TV.
So now it's about Trump and his reaction.
According to people close to the White House,
Donald Trump was furious.
Behind the scenes about the small rally crowd
before the rally even started.
Six of Donald Trump's ground team had already
tested positive for Corona virus.
That was the start of Trump being furious.
Trump mad that it got out that six of his
staff got the virus.
He wanted that information suppressed.
Then Trump had said he expected 22000 people
in the arena, 40000 more in overflow, expecting
more than 60000 people.
Ended up with sixty two hundred.
And Donald Trump became completely unhinged
and furious with his own campaign manager,
Brad Parr scale.
Reportedly, Trump's family, including Ivanka,
also furious with Brad Parr scale.
One outside adviser said, quote, This was
a major failure.
They tried lying about why the turnout was
small, offering up a lot of protesters, scared
off rally goers.
It was too hot.
The liberal media scared people about corona
virus.
Then they tried lying about the crowd, claiming
it was 12000.
But the fire department says now it was sixty
two hundred people.
But the constant thread throughout all of
this is Trump was losing his mind before and
after the rally.
There's a New York Times report which explains
that, quote, The president who had been warned
aboard Air Force One that the crowds at the
arena were smaller than expected.
I was stunned and he yelled at aides backstage
while looking at endless rows of empty blue
seats in the upper bowl of the stadium.
According to four people familiar with what
took place, Brad Parr scale, the campaign
manager who had put the event together, was
not present.
So the thinnest skinned president that we've
maybe ever had is furious again and with everybody
around him.
But I don't want to miss this opportunity
to refresh what is maybe a more important
conversation.
Whatever the reason for the failed turnout,
a problem they are up against is that they
have no coherent message for why Trump should
be reelected.
There are reports including that there are
growing concerns among the Trump campaign
officials that trump neither Trump nor his
team have a coherent message for why he should
be given a second term.
Hijinx and triggering aside the rally was
notable for the lack of actual campaign policy
message.
It was, look at me, I can drink water.
Corona virus is overblown.
Joe Biden is bad.
2016 was filled with promises he was obviously
not going to keep, but at least there were
promises.
I'll build the wall.
We'll repeal and replace Obamacare.
We'll fix trade.
None of it happened.
And now there's just nothing he can't really
run again on build the wall.
Right?
I mean, that would just expose that.
He failed to do it during his first term,
which is what he had promised to do.
Can he again run on replacing Obamacare?
The plan he proposed last time was terribly
unpopular and he's probably not going to have
the House of Representatives.
He he may not have the Senate remains to be
seen.
So what is the case for a second term?
Everything's terrible.
Tomorrow on the show, we're going to talk
about a new poll where Americans are saying
this is the worst moment in American history.
How do you justify your reelection? Trump
being furious is, of course, about the rally
itself.
But there is a bigger problem here, which
is what is the argument to get yourself reelected?
If you watched the rally, Eric Trump did a
bit of a warmup speech, which was insane,
and he brought up the war on Christmas.
That is something Trump talked about four
years ago.
So I guess we supposedly won the war on Christmas
because Trump is president.
But is that going to resonate with anybody
when we've got a 100 year pandemic going to
be?
Hopefully not.
But in the direction of 200000 deaths in the
U.S..
By the time of the election, historically
high unemployment like is talking about the
war on Christmas.
Going to work.
So we're going to devote more time to this
tomorrow.
What is the case Trump is making for his own
reelection?
Even aides are worried that there is really
no coherent case being made.
More
on that tomorrow.